what's up you guys movie retrospective
time and guess what anal probes yeah
this movie was something else i had
never seen it
i saw this movie a long time ago uh it
came out in 1989 so i probably saw it in
the early 90s like maybe when i was in
my late teens or like early 20s
and i didn't really remember anything
about it so i was like kind of curious
to revisit it
i had forgotten how
batshit insane this movie is and yet
this is really weird this is a bizarre
strange movie it's almost kind of like
it's bat [ __ ] insane
but at the same time it's also really
kind of boring yeah you know what i mean
i'm not really sure how how the film
manages to be both of those things
simultaneously but somehow
this is the naked lunch of ufos
yeah
you're like what the [ __ ] is going on
and what's [ __ ] what's [ __ ] weird
about this movie is that
had i seen this this come out in 81 and
i'd seen it as a kid it probably scared
me well now i have seen a lot of reviews
of this who the people that did see it
when they were kids and they did say
like the alien scenes in particular like
absolutely did scare them and i can see
that yeah i'd be like what the [ __ ] is
going on in this you know what i mean
and it's just kind of a meandering tale
of this dude who's obviously a crazy
person being played by christopher
walken who's crazy as [ __ ] as himself
and
he at random times gets abducted by
aliens other people kind of see it he
jokes with the aliens he high-fives the
aliens the aliens dance they're [ __ ]
creepy looking
um
it's a lot they rape him and he goes how
dare you
you put the [ __ ] anal thing up his
butt booty and it kind of like show
walking from weird angles like his knees
in between the camera and like and then
and it should have it's kind of [ __ ]
hilarious when you think about it as
noble as walking kind of kind of
sometimes comes across he allowed
himself to be in this role
where they put some up his booty and his
response was he looks man goes how dang
well is it we forget to mention that
even before that happens i like that the
aliens have like their anal probe is in
this like nice little you know kind of
hole in the wall thing that like it you
know you pull it out like it's a vacuum
it comes later it comes out like a snake
yeah it comes out like that and you know
they have it around just for such
occasions hey bring me the anal probe
glock or whatever your name is and so
they bring it out and before they stick
it in his booty hole though he actually
says can we talk about this
yeah yeah
it's [ __ ] weird man and it's one of
the weirdest movies i've ever seen yeah
and what's [ __ ] weird about it is
that the movie's well made it's a
well-made movie it's got a good score
eric clapton did the score actually and
you can tell it's very eric clapton yeah
it's shot pretty well
um the acting's good in it
uh it's the dialogue is just kind of
meandering and all over the place but i
think that's the way strieber is
um i think he wrote a book it's supposed
to be just like this right yeah i kind
of want to yeah i want to get into that
because uh yeah this is a whole thing
there's no real plot to it because it's
a paranormal experience on on his head
and you know i've i've had some [ __ ]
definitely paranormal experiences in my
family not just me but my whole family
and it wasn't it wasn't ufos or anything
but
later on i could talk about what i think
this is but
it doesn't really have a plot to it
which i understand that be because mine
didn't really have a plot to it either
it was just something that happened
but with this one
the chances of this being
extraterrestrial is about zero
zero although i believe he thought it
was
but
i kind of looked into it a little bit
more because i said now does he does
whitley strieber the author actually
believe that this happened to him and he
does
seem i don't think it's like an
amityville horror situation where i
think they just like made it up like to
write a book and make some money off it
i think he genuinely does him and
honestly communion was only the first
book that he wrote about his experiences
and i think he's since written
four or five more
like about the same thing and i think he
even like used some funds from the book
like to
to do like a
you know open like a group or like a you
know for people that had the same thing
go ahead and just jump forward
and nip this in the bug but i think this
is this is sleep paralysis i kind of
feel like it probably i've had it happen
to me and it is [ __ ] scary where you
have dreams and reality being
superimposed over itself and you're
awake but you're seeing dream material
interlaced with the room that you're in
and and uh it's a weird
feeling and um
you can also
i've noticed when that's happened to me
and it's happening probably six or seven
times
two or three the times that it happened
i thought like damn i can go out of my
body like astral projection from this
state because because i realized it was
an altered state of consciousness but i
couldn't do it you either wake up and
become fully lucid or you go back into a
dream
yeah it wasn't but it felt like you
could release your soul and go into the
damn astral plane which that's kind of
happened to me
and near-death experiences but
that's what he's talking about i don't
think it's extraterrestrials it's
he's got something wrong with his brain
they looked for it in the movie they
thought there might have been something
wrong with his brain they thought maybe
he had temporal lobe epilepsy there's
something going on in his brain which
allows him to have sleep paralysis
really easily and not be able to come
out of it
that's not a big problem it's just a
brain problem it's just
or might not be hardware maybe a
software maybe he well a lot of people
experience it
particularly under uh times of great
stress a lot of people i've had it
happen once
um it wasn't as
uh terrifying as some because i've known
some people that had it like regularly
and some of the [ __ ] they described was
like way worse than what i saw but i can
see how that should happen to you all
the time because it did absolutely seem
real even though
after a few seconds i was like i don't
think that's really there you know what
i
mean
so
when you watch this movie if you're a
big into ufos and [ __ ] don't look at
this as a ufo story that's not what this
is talking about it's
not even really paranormal although i
think paranormal things can happen
for in a in a um
in sleep paralysis
because
nbe or or [ __ ] obe out of body
experience which is like spontaneous out
of body experience which that's happened
to me
it was kind of like sleep paralysis when
it began but there was also our rsp
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis in
the room things shaking
like that and there was a witness that
saw it
i tell that story in another video
but so i'm not saying he's bullshitting
i'm just saying that this is a movie
really about sleep paralysis if you ask
me and i kind of suspect the streeper
might know that it was sleep paralysis
but that wouldn't make a very good book
or a very good movie would it
yeah i mean okay so the thing about this
i will note i don't think even in the
movie they don't mention
ufos or aliens i mean i think when he
goes to the support group the other
people do they see ufos but i think ufo
but he says well that's going back to
because i want to get into like whitley
strieber in the book and stuff a little
bit too because it's notable that in the
book
he never called them he never came out
and said that they were extraterrestrial
necessarily he just calls them visitors
like deep like and he's basically like
yeah they could be interdimensional they
could be extraterrestrial but they've
been here a long time there you know he
like left it open he's like i'm not
saying that that's what they are you
know what i mean yeah so
uh so in case you don't know whitley
strieber
prior to writing communion which came
out in 1987.
he was a pretty well-known very
successful generally horror writer i
think he wrote some fantasy as well uh
probably his best-known ones prior to
communion were the wolfen which was made
into the movie wolfen which we still
haven't reviewed that one either yeah i
remember this kid loved it and the
hunger green uh which was made into a
movie in 1983 with catherine de nov
susan sarandon and david bowie and still
remains one of my favorite vampire
movies ever this movie lives up to the
other two it does look that good it
looks good it's a good movie the story
is just not it's just weird i don't know
i didn't like it i just i kind of felt
like
i think it's a well-made movie it is i'm
not saying that yeah but there's a a
couple of structural problems i had with
it and okay so whitley strieber writes
communion it came out in 87
and he basically said this is an
experience that actually happened to me
it's a true story
happened to me and my family it was a
massive success and you have to think
this is 87 so i kind of feel like the
whole alien abductee thing while it had
been around it hadn't really been sort
of like codified into one narrative
around this time it was actually when
this movie when this book came out
communion you had a damn
professors at harvard looking at it
which all of a sudden this this subject
became legitimate and like oh whitley
street happened to him oh well then it's
got to be true there's something about
this during this time
for some reason alien abduction was
being taken seriously
yeah and i think this book was a large
part of solidifying that because
like i said it was a massive bestseller
he made all kind of money off of it and
so inevitably they decided they were
going to make a movie about it now the
guy that directed the movie you're going
to laugh when i say this uh philippe
mora who i think is australian
um he's directed a lot of other movies
but the ones that will probably make you
laugh are the howling two your sister is
a werewolf
and howling three
the marsupials
um so he's done some other ones too i
don't know if any of them are any good
uh howling too is terrible but um i've
never seen the third one
now okay
so they're gonna like adapt the book i'm
i think what they were going for they i
don't necessarily think they wanted to
make a horror movie they were trying to
make and i don't even think it's
marketed as a horror movie i think it's
more marketed more as like a sci-fi
drama thriller
uh that's based on someone's real
experiences and it seemed like they were
more interested in
exploring
the mental state that whitley streamer
was going through because like i said
the you know the book was he wrote the
book and said that's happened to him
so i think the movie was kind of more
interested in exploring that
now what they did though was they got
christopher walken to play whitley
strieber
everybody loves christopher walken
christopher walken is awesome
but i was trying to do his voice the
whole movie
but
i will say this may be an apocryphal
story i'm not entirely sure christopher
walken did absolutely not believe that
whitley schrieber had been abducted by
aliens or visitors or whatever
and he thought he was a crazy person
right so what so basically i don't know
if this is true but this supposedly
happened on set so they're doing this
well they let christopher walken uh
improvise a lot which if you've seen the
movie it will be very apparent yeah um
so apparently one time whitley schrieber
is on the set because obviously he's he
wrote the book and he also wrote the
screenplay
and he says to christopher walken
apparently hey you know you're playing
you know can you tone it down a little
bit you're pa you're playing me too
crazy
at which point christopher watkins says
to him if the shoe fits yeah
[Laughter]
i don't know if that's true but i hope
it is because that's pretty funny i know
you're crazy
he's trying to do his voice the whole
time but i can't really get the walking
thing down yeah i mean a lot of people
can't because a lot of people yeah a lot
of people can't do it like a really good
i i'm not one of those people i can't do
an impersonation of them either but i
hope that's true so
if you watch the movie as i said and
like i said i think christopher walken
is actually simultaneously again like
the best thing about this movie and the
worst thing about this movie had they
got someone other than christopher
walken to be in this it could have
actually been something kind of more
along the lines of maybe like fire in
the sky which was actually like a really
good
creepy
drama about somebody who supposedly
really got kidnapped by aliens
um but when they put christopher walken
in there and let him do
the walking thing he's walking the [ __ ]
out he is yeah and he is really at his
walkinest in this movie yeah um
it's
something
it's hard to explain if you've never
seen this movie movie would i i don't
think this would have attracted any
attention with that christopher
absolutely not absolutely not i think he
actually saves the movie that's what i
meant when i said that i mean like i
said if their intention was to make a
serious film about the psychological
ramifications of whether or not he did
get you know proved by the aliens or
whatever
the minute you put christopher walken in
there and let him do his thing
and knowing that christopher walken
thought that whitley strieber was a
crazy person and that none of this had
happened he is absolutely not taking any
of it seriously
and is reacting in really really weird
ways as a matter of fact okay this is
how i'm going to explain this film this
film
this is a movie about not
a not a person like a regular human
being
being kidnapped by aliens and you know
the repercussions that follow from that
this is about what would happen
if christopher walken the actual person
christopher walken was taken by aliens
and you were seeing a movie about how he
reacted to it because christopher walken
is a weirdo yeah so the way that he
reacts to everything in this movie is
not the way a normal person would react
to these situations and it's just so
bizarre yeah
sitting naked on a damn table on the
journey there in history because here i
am in front of you naked
you talk this over
guess not and then he starts waving to
him and they're waving back and [ __ ]
[ __ ]
weird [ __ ] weird man i mean i've seen
some weird movies it's like naked lunch
this is this maybe is weirder than naked
lunch yeah at least naked lunch like
at least you were expecting it to be i
was expecting this
like i said i haven't seen it in a long
time and i knew like i knew whitley
strieber i've read uh i don't i did read
communion but it was a long time ago
i've read the hunger i read the wolfen i
read some of his other stuff i had seen
this movie before but i didn't remember
anything about it so when i was going to
rewatch it i think i was expecting
something again more akin to like fire
in the sky which was more like a drama
about somebody who thinks they've been
kidnapped by aliens and they you know
like the fire in the sky like doesn't it
doesn't take a stand either way it's
just kind of exploring
what happens when you
i mean i just keep laughing they put
that thing up his booty and when they
pull it back out he looks at the [ __ ]
king and he goes how dare you
please tell me that somebody's made a
gif of that i mean they must have this
movie i feel like it's it's kind of
forgotten i feel like which is crazy
because more people should see it i'm
surprised it doesn't it does have a
little bit of a cult following but not a
huge one it actually aged pretty well
because it's just even more ridiculous
today i feel like this is eminently
memeable much because christopher walken
does some weird [ __ ] in this movie he's
playing whitley strieber whitley
strieber is a novelist
i don't know i don't know whitley
schreiber as a person i've never met him
yeah he's still alive in his 70s uh he
has a podcast too
it's called dreamland yeah yeah
and
so i've never met him as a person
i would imagine
that he is not
attempt as eccentric as christopher
walken portrays him in this movie
christopher walken i don't know if
whitley schroeber really does this okay
i don't know novelists are weird i'm a
novelist but i'm not this weird i'm
pretty normal as far as far as novelists
go but
he's like dressing up in costumes in his
house like working on his working on his
work and put you know putting on like
fedoras and putting doing german accents
yeah and he's just and like one time
what was that whole thing like before he
goes to like meet up with the aliens and
make peace with the aliens or whatever
at the end and he comes into the house
dressed up like he has the fedora and
the thing and he comes in like singing
like putting on the ritz and he's like
but there's no like explanation he's
just doing that but he's a crazy person
it's just very very odd it's just the
choices that he makes of this are really
really odd maybe christopher walken
thought this is the dumbest [ __ ] ever
and i'm just gonna like ham the [ __ ] out
of it just to like to amuse myself well
what's funny is that it doesn't
it doesn't really this probably would
have been a lot better as a book it's
just that that doesn't really fit in a
movie of this topic the it's the kind of
like tonal
it's tonal lash i guess you can yeah
yeah so it just comes off as kind of
like insanity or no not really insanity
it comes off as surrealism
some people that are into like ufo films
or think that they have been abducted
themselves
um i've actually heard a couple of them
commend this movie because of the
surrealism and the ridiculousness
because they said that was closer to
what we experienced what i'm saying man
this is the strangeness yeah this is
this is sleep paralysis that's what
they're yeah i think it is sleep pro now
here here's the thing okay i wanted to
get into this now about this is about
time probably get into it
so many people might go and be real big
into the ufology which i'm i'm into that
too there's some ufo cases out there
that uh [ __ ] no i think that should
happen like the real phoenix lights case
i think that was real uh some of the
stuff involving like airliners um
and and ufo uh ufo stuff like [ __ ] uh
jafari from the uh iraqi air force my
granddad was in isfahan at that time
with uh grumman aerospace
[ __ ] selling those f-14 tomcats and
trying to teach the shah's men on how to
[ __ ] work those things because he was
he was from that company
and
they heard about they were asked
questions if they were building a
supersonic reconnaissance planes for the
iraqis in secret because they'd pick
some up on a damn satellite something
moving out at about mach 12
in that area so something was there
there was nothing could go mach 12 in
those days
you know
i don't even think because i don't think
they had supersonic scramjet rockets i
don't think at that point
but uh
and the chances of it being an error at
that place in that time where
fighter pilots are saying they're seeing
big [ __ ] light lit up craft anyway i
was getting that
the
modern the modern understanding
of ufology and extraterrestrials and
exobiology and the distances involved
between planets and what kind of
technology you need
really wasn't around in the 80s and the
90s the average person
really didn't have a good grasp on on
this
they thought that
a small ship
could travel between the stars and land
and that biological beings in there
might need to collect samples from cows
and from people and maybe look up inside
your booty and [ __ ] get readings off
you because they might need to know this
[ __ ] and then they go back to wherever
they came from
all right
know what we know now no that's [ __ ]
highly unlikely highly unlikely
for a lot of different reasons
if an extraterrestrial
civilization can make it here to this
planet they probably have been able to
make it here for hundreds of thousands
of years or thousands of years which
means that they were here a long time
ago
and if they know everything about this
planet already
they would know about our dna they
wouldn't know how it all works
they would could come here and just with
a few drops of water and a few drops of
blood from animals and look at dna they
would know everything about human beings
because that would be real
common to them they would understand
that kind of biology because there's
nothing really special about us
they would look at our dna and go oh
yeah we've seen this before we know how
this works
oh okay that's how they're built there's
no reason for them to hold you down and
abduct you
and stick something up in your booty
maybe they're just like space fetishists
uh when you
maybe they just enjoy it yeah that's
funny but no
no
yeah just make it a joke they're not
coming yeah and then
and then another thing is is that uh
what we know now the chances of them
being biological is very
slim
it's going to be something kind of like
out of 2001 it's going to be a living
machine type thing
that is alive and has a soul i guess
like the monolith
you know that's a godlike thing
that looks at you like we would look at
a
single-celled organism and maybe it can
create life
so they wouldn't really be too mystified
or curious that much because they would
have seen lots of places like earth and
they would just
not be all that interested probably
they look at humans oh those those might
eventually evolve into living machines
and then we'll come back and we'll talk
to them
yeah you know we're always putting
ourselves at the center of everything
you know we used to put the sun at the
center of the universe
we used to put the earth at the center
of the universe actually
now
actually the sun is in the center of the
solar system yeah we just constantly get
knocked off our perches right so there's
no reason that that wouldn't happen
again yeah the chances are we're
insignificant and that's okay yeah it's
okay chances are you
have been here know all about this place
and we're a backwater that's not not
even very interesting and the aliens are
just meh yeah man
we'll come back in a few million years
maybe they'll have living machines maybe
they'll be smart then yeah well wouldn't
they come on us
things that we create might be smart one
day we're part of a process
so uh no when you look at these
stories like this
they start to look a lot like the
stories of the 1950s of the big old fat
dude who's 50 years old in his coveralls
says yeah i was out in the cornfield and
the [ __ ] ufo landed and out came a
beautiful extraterrestrial woman with
long [ __ ] gold hair
with big old boobs and she wanted to
have sex with me
dudes used to say that kind of [ __ ] yeah
i know
yeah
and uh but that stories like this start
to sound like stories like that so this
didn't happen
or well obviously i mean this movie yeah
this is sleep paralysis on now i will
say though that just as a movie like if
we're not looking at it from you know
the fact of this supposed to be based on
a true story like on paper
it sounds like it actually could have
been really good like really creepy you
know what i mean like if you talk about
it because okay so at the beginning you
have willie strieber
who's a writer he's had some successful
horror novels but he's kind of have like
a little bit of writer's block he's
having trouble like coming up with his
next idea or whatever he's got a wife
and a kid like a son
and so they decide well they need to get
away from the city they set it in uh
they lived in manhattan
they so they have a cabin like up in
upstate new york presumably
so they go up there with two of their
friends like another couple
and they're gonna go up there now the
first night that they're there and i
think this is like in the fall like in
october or whatever
so the first night that they're there
they're all awakened now he has like all
these burglar alarms i guess he's
paranoid or something but he has like
all these burglar alarms and like uh you
know motion lights and sensors and [ __ ]
like that like outside the thing so they
don't get any prowlers so those are
bright but the first night that they're
there they're woken up in the middle of
night by like a super super bright light
which you're led to assume is like some
kind of craft like hovering over the
thing they never show it it's just like
a really bright light
now
christopher walken wakes up
and he doesn't really see anything or so
he thinks like he there's just like a
big bright light and you see like a tiny
little maybe little gray alien type
situation like peeking around a doorway
which a lot of people like i said if
they said they saw it as kids and they
thought it was really creepy which i can
see that because it is kind of creepy
his kid starts screaming his head off
and the wife stays asleep now the next
morning
he doesn't really remember what happened
um but the other couple like especially
the guy are like i don't like it here we
need to get the [ __ ] out of here i don't
like i don't like what the [ __ ] happened
last night and i don't like it so he
makes
like christopher walken like he makes
them all leave so they all leave
now after this christopher walken goes
back to his regular life but essentially
starts to
exhibit signs of like ptsd essentially
like he starts having uh flashbacks and
nightmares um about what he saw even
though he claims he doesn't remember it
and he's starting to kind of flip out
they have like they find this kind of
like thing in the back of his head where
it looked like uh you know something was
stuck in there and so he
has to he gets crazier and crazier his
wife's like look i can't put up with
your [ __ ] anymore you're like acting
like a nut case and so he goes to a
doctor they do like the temporal lobe
epilepsy [ __ ] on him and then they're
like okay well maybe you need to go to a
psychiatrist and then the psychiatrist
hypnotizes him at which point he starts
to remember
all of the like seeing the aliens and
the anal probe and all that other kind
of stuff interestingly the aliens in
this they have two different they're i
keep calling them aliens and whitley
streeper is very adamant that he doesn't
call them that he's not saying that
they're not extraterrestrials he's just
saying that
he doesn't know what they are and so
he's not saying he's like i'm not
necessarily saying they're from another
planet maybe they are i don't know he's
like i don't know what they were but
there's two kinds you have one kind that
looks very much like the standard gray
alien with like the little face and the
big black bug eyes and it's like really
skinny and like little and then you have
like some little
white christopher walken calls little
blue [ __ ] or blue midgets that kind
of look a little bit like the little
midgety things from phantasm yeah that's
what i was thinking um except
yeah they but they look like little
trolls
or you know a little
little creatures like that and they kind
of purse their little lips all the time
yeah i got little human faces yeah but
the weird thing about this and maybe
this is a spoiler the weird thing about
this and whitley schrieber said this in
his book too
is that and they show this at the end of
the movie is that even though that's
what the two types of
visitors look like
um that's not actually what they look
like because they're they're masks yeah
because at one point like one of the
gray looking aliens like the bottom of
its thing breaks off and it looks kind
of like an insecty green kind of thing
and then at one point two like you see
one of the little blue [ __ ] and it's
just like a head like someone's taking
the mask off so the director even said
you know whitley strieber said that the
aliens he doesn't really know what they
look like because he got the impression
that they were wearing masks yeah it
which is weird in itself and kisses him
every now and then yeah it's funny [ __ ]
he does he makes out with one of the
little blue ones at some point and it's
like what
yeah and then i mean there's so many
like what the [ __ ] scenes in this which
like i said it could have worked because
if you sort of framed it as oh it's not
necessarily aliens but it's somebody
with sleep paralysis or somebody who's
like maybe losing their mind yeah um
some of the surreal imagery i think does
work um i think it is like really creepy
but then some of it
just goes way too far over onto like the
ridiculous eye i mean like there's
scenes where he's you know he's dreaming
quote unquote or supposedly like
remembering what happened to him when he
got abducted
and he's in this
is it a steam bath
he's like a steam bath yeah and then
there's like the little gray aliens are
kind of like floating around behind him
going
yeah dancing and floating yeah it's
ridiculous and i'm not exaggerating
that's they're just like almost like a
little 60s dance and [ __ ]
yeah with their little noodly arms it's
the craziest thing ever
he's having sleep paralysis
one of the times when it happened to me
i just woke up and saw the room and it
was all [ __ ] kind of like a uh
kind of star patterny or not starving it
was gonna be looking at like uh
it's hard to say
but it was just dark in there and i
looked over to the wall next to me i
couldn't move and a three foot tall face
started to come out of the wall
like a image of a face started to warp
out of it
and that
i almost started getting scared but then
i realized that oh i'm dreaming and it
just faded away the one that [ __ ]
freaked me out didn't happen we had my
friend jason and he told me he said he
woke up in the middle of the the night
couldn't move it was dark in the room
and he didn't know why he woke up and he
looked out the foot of bed and there was
somebody sitting at the foot of his bed
he said it was small about the size of a
small child
it was hunched over he could just see a
black silhouette and as he's looking at
it he tried to scream or you know what i
mean he couldn't move and as he was
looking at it and all of a sudden it
turned around and looked at it and then
[ __ ] he just lost it and it vanished
i would [ __ ] my [ __ ] pants if i could
have been saw that seriously
i couldn't move i couldn't move yeah and
then he finally relaxed up and then he
then he moved and got up when he got
some water
i mean if you've ever seen have you ever
seen the documentary that's called the
nightmare yeah that's about sleep
paralysis yeah it's actually it's
actually pretty good and it has like a
bunch of people that suffer from it and
they are like describing their
experiences and stuff and so some of the
[ __ ] was like terrifying and as it was
winding down he said he had this [ __ ]
overwhelming feeling of a presence in
the room even though it was gone but it
was he could still like he yeah he
thought maybe it was really there which
that
kind of
lead
that's what they're talking about about
incubus and succubus and [ __ ]
and stuff like stories like this
well people they used to have nightmares
i think is exactly what they're talking
about yeah well they used to call it hag
ridden
yeah like because they people perceived
that there was like a witch or something
like that like sitting on their chest
yeah and they couldn't breathe or move
and then there was like this horrifying
thing right there but that's what they
used to call it sitting on your chest
well i guess that's kind of like sitting
on the edge of your bed yeah
he thought it was sitting at the edge of
the bed and woke him up well i mean have
you ever seen that uh
that very famous henry fucelli painting
the nightmare that's what that depicts
like somebody's sleeping with like a
little gremlin like a little gremlin
like perched on our chest like that so
it's a it's a pretty common experience
like a lot of people have it like i said
even people that don't suffer from it a
lot like have had it once or twice like
if they're going through like a real
stressful time in their life um like i
said i've had it happen at one time but
that's and it wasn't that bad it was
creepy but it wasn't that bad what i
think streamers talking about sleep
paralysis he's having some kind of it
would explain yeah it would explain a
lot of smears of sleep and like i said i
do feel like
you know it's been a long time since i
read the book
i do feel like there is a good if you
didn't take a stand one way or the other
whether you thought it was real or sleep
paralysis or whatever
you could actually make a really creepy
movie out of this
it's just that they got christopher
walken in there and he
obviously wasn't really taking it all
that seriously they let him improv
so he was just doing like bizarre things
like he would be like he would be woken
woken up by you know the bright light or
whatever and then like the aliens or the
little blue people would come into the
room and he would just look at instead
of being scared he would just like laugh
he'd be like what the [ __ ] you know what
i mean like almost like he was laughing
at the makeup effects yeah and uh so it
kind of like it was just a very very
strange like juxtaposition yeah but um
yeah the way they okay so they he goes
to you know he gets hypnotized and he
starts remembering things and then his
wife is obviously like you must be
losing your [ __ ] marbles but then
their kid who has also seen it says
something that like matches up with
something he said so she's like oh maybe
there's something to it so she goes and
gets hypnotized and then it turns out
that even though during the first
uh encounter she was thought she was
asleep the whole time but in the
hypnotizer she actually saw some weird
[ __ ] too so then she actually starts to
believe him and then they go to this
group
of other abductees which is actually
like pretty funny and he like thinks all
their that they're kind of all crazy
yeah and then he decides and they don't
really like
the weird thing about this movie well
okay so it the weird thing about this
movie that i think made it like
simultaneously bizarre and boring at the
same time one thing this movie did
structurally that i thought was really
uh unnecessary
it would show you most of what happened
like here's the event like the bright
light and this little alien peeking or
whatever and then later on
christopher walken would go to the
doctor's office and get hypnotized and
then he would tell you what happened i'm
like but we already saw that yeah you
know what i'm saying so it seemed a
little like repetitive
like he just kept saying the same thing
i saw this bright light i'm like yes
we've established that you saw a bright
light outside the window and then you
saw a little these little things like
peeking and it just seemed like there
was too much repetition was like yes we
know what he saw yeah like we've we've
already seen it and then he's already
talked about it one time
because if you're doing a movie just
show it and you don't have don't show it
and then like a couple scenes later have
somebody like describing what you just
[ __ ] saw you know
normal life and he's talking about
writing books instead it's just not
it's not real com the edit is not very
compelling it has to be more streamlined
and go through it is very meander it has
to be almost like a damn ride yeah going
through it it's meandering and it
repeats itself too much it repeats
itself you can't fix it now it's been
too long because you already know i mean
going into it i'm presuming that most of
the people that saw this movie had read
the book they're like look we know that
you think you've been abducted by
visitors or aliens or whatever um we
don't really need to waste any time in
the movie establishing that
um
and if you're gonna i you know i figure
if you're gonna
show the event
just show the event don't have him
in the hypnotist office later
saying it over again because we already
saw it and you and they had all they had
um all the special effects already made
they just should have showed more
more of the abduction scenes longer
weirder [ __ ] happening you didn't need
all the like i said you didn't need too
much of him going to the [ __ ] shrink
i mean you could have that but like you
know shorten those
you don't need him like describing
everything that we already saw show it
yeah don't just show somebody talking
about it
um you know and definitely don't do both
things because i'm like yeah we've
established this because
it doesn't work in a movie exactly and
we've talked about that a lot of times
so i think that was probably i think
that was the main problem i had with
just the edit of it and the structure of
it was it seemed very repetitive and
there was a lot of scenes in there that
didn't need to be in there yeah it
seemed a little bit long it's an hour
and 48 minutes and i think they easily
they yeah and yeah it felt longer than
that they easily could have chopped 20
minutes out of that no problem at all
um uh
for one reason too like you know the
friend like the the man of the couple
that they go up to you know that had the
way and they have a conversation with
him and i don't know if this is based on
a real guy or not they made him eastern
european and i think they only made him
eastern european so he could bring up
the folklore of the kobold of the kobold
yeah um so that was kind of them
introducing oh maybe it's not
necessarily aliens or maybe if it is
aliens they've been here a long time and
a lot of different cultures have
folklore about them which is fascinating
and i kind of wish they'd gone more in
that direction
um rather than having christopher walken
toward the end and he doesn't say that
he's gonna do this he doesn't really
explain his motivation for doing any of
this stuff but like toward the end he's
like just comes in singing putting on
the ritz or whatever for
some strange reason and then he says to
his wife i'm gonna go get some
cigarettes
and then he leaves and she's like you
don't smoke and then he drives all the
way back up to upstate new york to the
cabin
and goes to he sees this light in the
woods and he goes in there into their
ship presumably and like hangs with them
and then while he's in there and he
dances with him yeah and then there's a
doppelganger of him that looks kind of
like a magician or something and then
there's a doppelganger of his wife there
who looks kind of like is it like a
flapper or like a glamour
type of situation and i'm like what in
the actual [ __ ] is going on here this is
what he saw and like i said it's maybe
that's what he saw
but in a movie and maybe some of the
people that saw this movie and just
thought it would be like a creepy sci-fi
whatever maybe they should have
contextualized that a little bit more is
what i'm saying and also they didn't go
much into
i think they established that
and this isn't established very well but
i think they established that once he
starts remembering all the stuff that
happened
he remembers that when he was a little
kid he saw the bright light and and the
the visitors too
and then this leads him to conclude that
this is something that is passed on in
families like if you so his son will
also have contact with the visitors like
he's chosen or special or something
and that wasn't really gone into all
that sufficiently a lot of stuff in here
is just like unexplained
and it's not i'm not saying everything
has to be explained i'm just saying that
there's not like a lot of
like a real compelling reason for some
of the characters particularly him to be
doing what they're doing i didn't really
get like why
why did he drive up there and just say
well i'm gonna make peace with them but
that he didn't really like establish or
say that that's what he was gonna do
naked lunch doesn't establish anything
either that's why yeah but naked lunch
is supposed to be well that's a reality
this is the this is the naked lunch of
[ __ ] this is supposed to kind of be i
thought like a coherent so maybe not no
i mean i i kind of do feel like they
were trying to maybe
i mean the director did seem to
want to
approach like what whitley schruber said
that he saw
which doesn't really make a lot of sense
it makes sense when you look at it from
the point of view of sleep paralysis
well yeah that's what i mean but it
doesn't make like like narrative senses
when you're having sleep paralysis
sometimes you're all it starts in a damn
waking dream yeah where you're dreaming
and you're totally in the dream world
but you become conscious
inside that dream even though you think
you're not dr you don't realize you're
dreaming
and then you'll see some weird [ __ ]
happen and it's bizarre and then you
might go wait a minute hold on am i
dreaming
and then you're in [ __ ] sleep
paralysis you're awake looking but you
can't move because you've now because
you woke up from a deep sleep and the
[ __ ] that part of your brain that
that
is still turned off to keep you from
acting out so you're paralyzed
but then you have you can now see but
some of you that dream material is
superimposed over what you see and
so a person who doesn't know what the
hell is happening would be real could
get real confused about what's real and
what's not real
they would still think that they're
still that they were awake in another
world
and now they're back and they can see
the room and the aliens are in the room
with them that's what this is about yeah
it's just well i never give you that
[ __ ] context but what he's saying the
stories he's telling fit that symptom
yeah
i'm just saying that if
if you're if we want to approach the
movie as
this is an experience he actually had
rather than framing it as we don't know
what this was because it seems like they
wanted to frame it as this is an
experience he actually had rather than
making it more ambiguous as in is he
losing his mind was it just sleep
paralysis or whatever
but if you were gonna do that i kind of
feel if you're gonna go like in a more
experiential direction if you want to
call it that i think that they should
have made it more
cohesive
or at least explained it a little bit
more
um
or given reason why certain things were
going on the way it is the way they just
kind of left it it just seems
kind of silly i think they i think it
was supposed to be a trip
it i think it was i you know i think to
some degree they were trying to do that
i just don't think they were very
successful
because even in 89 i mean even if you'd
gone the surrealist route yeah you could
i wish they would have made the
imagery
creepier because the imagery was just
very silly what what this if you ask me
mel gibson came and kind of [ __ ]
improved this story made signs or was
that mel gibson did science no he was in
it it wasn't it was m night um
that's right
signs was kind of like this but a lot
more coherent
this movie i mean like i said
if you want to see
a purportedly true
alien abduction story that's actually
creepy and actually goes into like the
psychological trauma behind it and blah
blah blah then watch fire in the sky
yeah don't watch this one
absolutely fire in the sky is a lot
better yeah um and it's coming from like
the same place as this yeah this movie
though i think it's worth watching
though if you're into like ufo [ __ ] just
so you can see how [ __ ] strange it is
well it's also it's so strange it
doesn't really come across as a ufo
movie coming it comes now it was closer
to to like something like the exorcist
or some or amityville horror almost kind
of like a damn haunted house or
paranormal type move something in the
damn house and it's getting you and then
you're in another world and it comes but
it's not scary like there's a couple
image images in it that are kind of
creepy it would have scared me if i was
a kid and that probably would have
scared you if you were little yeah um
but a lot of it is honestly a lot of it
is just christopher walken and the i
can't remember the actress name that uh
played his wife she was in all the
president's men and stuff um but it's
just them kind of like [ __ ] around
like making jokes and him being weird
yeah and her being like what the [ __ ]
and you know it's it's that kind of
stuff like
which i guess was meant to establish
like characters so you would care but it
just came off as like weird and bizarre
like what is this oddball
doing and like what you know what i mean
so just i don't know it just it came
across a very strange experiment
experience to me
um i now like i said this came out the
book was a massive success as i said it
came out at 87. this came out at 89 and
not surprisingly was a huge commercial
flop
um
because i can see why now i have seen
like some people that particularly
people that are really scared by a by
alien horror like alien abduction horror
which i'm not
um you know i'm not saying that some
sci-fi horror isn't scary because it is
but any of these kind of like oh aliens
coming to earth and like kidnapping
people that is like never scary to me i
don't know why it's just not scary and i
guess because i just can't suspend my
disbelief that far
and so
but i have seen that some people that
are like creeped out by that actually do
like this movie but i think most people
acknowledge
that this is like a [ __ ] oddball
movie and as i said it's i know this is
weird to say that this is simultaneously
one of the weirdest and also one of the
most boring films i've ever seen and
that christopher walken is the best
thing about it and the worst thing about
it at the same time he's the best thing
about it i mean it's worth watching for
him yeah it's the strangest i found this
youtube video earlier today that's
called walking 101 and it's like a guy
and he's like it's he's like it's like
he's teaching a class on christopher
walken it's like really funny and he so
and he does like each of his movies and
i watched like the communion one today
and it was like [ __ ] hilarious but
it's just and they went really into this
there are so much for watching watch a
[ __ ] bet you're walking watches that
kind of [ __ ]
i would if i was yeah maybe he has
better things to do i don't really know
but like i said he seems to be having a
good time in this movie
um if he wasn't in it i think it would
have been forgotten this movie would
have never gotten bigger um but just the
fact that it's like so [ __ ] totally
bizarre
that and because the imagery is so silly
and even when it's scary like the way
that christopher walken reacts to it
seems more like christopher walken the
person would react to it than like a
regular person would be really
out of this [ __ ] you could give that you
could be i am imagining i didn't look i
should have looked i feel like there's
probably gifts oh galore because he's
got somebody like weird [ __ ] hanging
out with that [ __ ] ugly ass alien and
[ __ ] winking at the alien
weird kind of chat
my favorite thing i mean other than the
whole anal probe scene because i was
joking at first
i couldn't remember if christopher
walken got anally probed in this
so i was already making anal probe jokes
but then i was like oh [ __ ] he does get
anally prone to this i forgot i was
making a joke and it wasn't even a joke
and when he says how when he says how
dare you it's like he's not even mad
that was the thing that he's like i was
kind of excited
he's like i'm gonna try to do it
how dare you
how dare you like somebody just like
spilled some ash on his coat or
something it was fun
it was hooked up to like a tube or like
a pipe it was so i'm assuming they were
shooting something up in there or they
were pulling something out i'm not
running
that came down and looked inside the
house
yeah it was like that said it happened
well they just gave him a free they were
just looking up in there they gave him a
free colon exam yeah sure
maybe
it kind of looked like a gas pump yeah a
little bit
like a
little bit
how dare you
like i said his reactions to this
are not that i think that's what would
that's what got me i think that was just
kind of like because i could just cut
all the alien [ __ ] scenes up and just
[ __ ] watch walking you just put that
[ __ ] on under the endless loop it's
better it's the best part i mean
honestly yeah you could take out all of
the other like the you know the parts of
him like farting around with his family
because that's boring
um and and even like the parts of him
like in the hypnotist office where he's
just talking about stuff that's already
happened that's also boring you don't
need that because they've already shown
it yeah just when he's with the aliens
but yeah when he's with the aliens
yeah you should just like cut all that
together and it might only be 15 or 20
minutes long and that would probably be
like [ __ ] comedy gold yeah like
because him just said i'm sitting i'm
naked yeah
and what do you have to say about it we
sound like we're making this up we're
not making it up i'm thinking it's in
front of you we're stopping
i'm sitting here
christopher walken high five today yeah
he goes guys a piece of wood
just making coffee he's sitting in a
[ __ ] thing in their ship and there's
for real a grey alien floating behind
him going
when he says you're above me you're
putting yourself above me or something
like that it's just some weird [ __ ] it's
one it's the weirdest thing i've ever
seen
it's not a good movie it's not no it's
not but
it's it it's
[ __ ] hilarious in it
i mean if you're into christopher walken
you you really have to see this to
believe it and what's funny seriously
it's funny is that it's well made
yeah it's a well-made movie but it's not
really all it's boring mostly boring
that's yeah that's kind of like the
shame of it is like i said i i feel like
if you cut out all the family stuff and
all that's not important yeah everybody
just wants to see christopher walken
getting down with the aliens and getting
his butt probed yeah and evidently it's
not i'd watch that it's not just me
saying this because it flopped back in
the day yeah they probably thought it
was boring too
and it sounds like when you describe it
it sounds like it wouldn't be boring no
and parts of it aren't like parts of it
you're it comes it goes from like you're
dozing off and then you're like what the
[ __ ] you know it's like that yeah it's
that it's that kind of situation but for
long stretches it's kind of like
yes and then you're like wait what yeah
it's like that so there's some parts but
anytime there's like some family [ __ ]
just skip over that yeah and then just
get to the next like part of the day
that's it yeah but yeah so
this movie it's on to be uh for free
right we watched it on tv yeah yeah um
yeah if you're into chris for walking go
watch it you absolutely won't believe it
and now i'm gonna go like check for
[ __ ] gifts because i'm sure there's
all kind of like fun gifts about this
i'm gonna have to put some of them in
the in the [ __ ] comment section but
yeah so uh that'll do it for movie
retrospective don't uh go get yourself
anally probe by aliens until we see you
next time and we'll see you next time
bye